voici mon blog au japon j'ai été pour le
tournage de mon prochain court-métrage
et cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north
vpn je les remercie et je vous parle du
sponsor un peu plus tard dans la vidéo
mon expérience là-bas a été incroyable
et j'espère que cette vidéo à vous
plaire bon visionnage
la venue chez moi pour une petite partie
de street fighter c'est pas vrai du tout
on est à l'aéroport direction le japon
voilà des vrais jeux vidéo notamment
fermés c'est parti pour deux heures de
vol je pars avec françois descraques qui
réalise le court métrage et une partie
de l'équipe technique et 12 heures c'est
long et chiant et 12 heures enfermé un
peu d'air frais de l'art japonais
voilà le timing est plutôt chargé il ya
pas mal de choses à préparer pour le
tournage
mais d'abord il faut manger ça fait une
heure que l'arrivée à tokyo et c'est
parti tran j'ai un très bon ramel je
m'attendais à une expérience
certainement un million c'est bon ils
traquent immense
[Musique]
là on va sur le pont de mes gros pour un
repérage on va sur google strict et
personnes celui d'un et là maintenant
[Musique]
bonjour fraîchement réveiller
aujourd'hui c'est une grande journée
pour séjourner opéra a opéré plusieurs
décors pour le court métrage on va
tourner d'ici quelques jours et c'est
aussi le début de la transformation de
cette année fois qu'on va cyprien
cyprien au revoir et ben j'imagine c'est
parti vous savez j'aime bien sur les
lieux pour faire une fiction mes petits
sketches donc là on s'est dit un petit
décolorés pas mal non
tu sais que tu aimes bien dans mes rêves
est parfait petit passe aussi après le
soir elle t'attend vers la même chose
qui dit japon riffaud catcheur c'est mon
seul essai il y à 100% de chances que
j'échoue je ne m'aime pas et d'en
regarder gardé une dent
[Musique]
la transformation déjà commencé vous le
savez il reste encore une étape très
importante
[Musique]
non les proches de justin gorge
aujourd'hui on va faire la rencontre des
comédiens les essayages aussi pour tous
les comédiens auto et dans deux jours où
va-t-on désormais en se rend à takeshita
dolly c'est l'endroit pour acheter plein
de trucs très kawaii mignon j'ai pour ça
pour toi mais bien un truc était le plus
instagram est attaquée chat doré tu vois
pas je pense à elle sorti d'affaires
coc
c'est par là on a la base je voulais
acheter des barbapapas arc en ciel mais
en fait j'avais trop de queue du coup
j'ai trouvé quelque chose d'encore mieux
en un petit peu prend la moitié du bossu
me du bon fromage je n'ai pas y est avec
ça alors moi je le fais moi ça ça repas
typique au japon c'est pas vrai
prochaine devrait jouer un jeu psp mine
sans regarder derrière choisi un chiffre
entre 1 10 5 5 en 3 ans et 10 mois c'est
une crêpe cheesecake vais vous dire
pourquoi je n'étais pas serein je t'ai
pas serein parce qu'il y avait aussi au
thon chili
il y avait des crêpes pizzas tout ce qui
est au delà de trois cinq dix et j'étais
pas bien
maintenant on va choisir celle de
françois foisy - o'shea le 8
[Rires]
donc on a dit caramel glace vanille et
c'est la vente des bananes non oui si
c'est parti pour le premier vrai jour de
tournage dit vrai jour parce que pour
l'instant on a déambulé dans tokyo
je suis chez moi maintenant on va enfin
faire des répliques en japonais avec des
comédiens japonais comme par exemple
toro nanofils taux s'est jetée masse
c'est-à-dire nous cherchons chine
je crois
[Musique]
ah bon et oui on est en plein shibuya et
il ya un spot à youtube heures je ne
connaissais pas
c'est de gagner des abonnés au japon
réactions et picon la romagne et voilà
comment gagner des abonnés je m'abonne à
des chaînes
[Musique]
chico photo hachiko c'est la célèbre
statue d'un chien à qui tarde à shibuya
on m'a dit tu donnes et labatt
un an c'est foutu de la gueule c'est une
race de chats ils perpétuent chebeya
crossing peut-être le croisement le plus
connu de l'univers c'est aussi peut-être
le plus emprunté du monde avec beaucoup
beaucoup de monde beaucoup de gens qui
viennent ici et on se rend au restaurant
abonnés tokyoïte
ce soir nous avons mangé des okonomiyaki
qui sont un mélange d'omelette est en
fait simple
voilà mais les japonais dont il est tout
à fait dans la passé qu'on peut faire
soi même sur une plaque
donc voici la place bienvenue dans
tutour au coût de vie active et à à
aller à tokyo à lyon déjà pour la
prémisse à mélanger voilà il commençait
bien mélanger et faire sur la notice
parce que oui une notice le co nominé
qui doit mesurer 14 cm de diamètre si
les fans réclament quelque chose fait 14
centimètres plus de poids à l'utiliser
pour mesurer mais bon on s'enterre
s'invite au mieux tout le monde sait
très bien qu'il a dit je prends
franchement aller ça passe ça passe
quatre minutes
c'est parti pour la nouvelle étape ils
font retourner le cognac et dessins
nouvelle étape la sauce bulldogs
on ajoute à ça la mayonnaise est très
important c'est le dressage
je propose d'araignée est un peu échoué
[Musique]
tulle coupe du monde c'est ton premier
au cou depuis mon premier mais c'est
l'instant l'instant avoue c'est pas moi
qui les presse me l'a donnée comme ça
aujourd'hui disgression dans notre
quotidien et dans notre tournage
puisqu'on est avec sochan g photographe
et qui vit désormais à tokyo et on avait
déjà fait un shooting photo
maintenant qu'elle est là on s'est dit
pays theron l'exploit de faire un petit
shooting photos ici à tokyo
photo à tokyo c'est comme ça
[Musique]
bienvenue à as aqsa devant le ta mine à
limone fameuses grandes lanternes et
tout au bout et le temple sensoji on a
les deux petits commerces très prisée
des touristes et touristes mois des
parades et des porte-clés et des petites
cloches que tu mets notamment
il est l'heure de tirer une prédiction
un petit truc très typique de sensoji tu
prends une boîte tu mélanges chaque
agent string
[Musique]
et sur une baguette avec un numéro et
numéro 26 j'en sais rien secure
japonaise maintenant deux scénarios des
tirs et une bonne prédiction ou une
mauvaise traduction ici une bonne tu la
gardes avec toi tu vas maison compte
hortefeux y tu deviens heureux dans la
vie c'est une mauvaise tu l'as pris en
caves et tu fais un petit noeud conjurer
le sort
c'est scientifiquement prouvé bonne
augure tu fus un temps japonais vous
entendez l'appel d'un kop le matin
autres temps est venu vous serez plus
heureux comme un voilier avant je le
vend ses écrits en anglais et bassa
directo into my portefeuille est bien
d'avoir une excellente
je vais avoir des trésors par véhicule
entier qui vont venir dans ma maison ont
déjà juré maison c'est bien la cible et
j'aurais véhicule par vécu en scène
précise c'est vraiment et quand je vais
monter à cheval tout on va me saluer
parce que c'est mon cheval
pareil sur un cheval c'est bon à savoir
viens de voir ça en quête douze mois
achevée
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant on va les déposer un peu
dansant pour se purifier l'âme
[Musique]
j'ai donné 20 yens ça fait 16 centimes h
un peu ras bord
[Musique]
on
bienvenue au parc louis henno où les
gens viennent profiter des fleurs de
cerisier faire le hanami c'est à dire
regarder les fleurs de ses réserves
[Musique]
bienvenue au barbecue japonais à remplir
seibert regardez bien dessus
velisek au japon
en irak
[Musique]
on va les rencontrer inio asano un manga
carte qui a fait les mangas solanin
bonne huile pon pon
j'ai hâte de le rencontrer et je vais
peut-être lui demander une petite
dédicace s'il veut bien plus c'est notre
dernier jour à tokyo
maintenant je vais en profiter pour me
changer de style je n'étais pas plus oui
cette gueule déjà aux un petit peu
choqué loin de cette vidéo
eh bien elle va encore changer grâce à
ceci parce que j'ai envie d'avoir les
cheveux roses pas vraiment c'est en
japonais donc je comprend rien on va
essayer au feeling et écrit juste only
cinq minutes speech flavor donc c'est un
de pêche mais je ne mangerai pas les
sportifs
[Musique]
j'ai vu la coiffeuse faire sa propre
puisqu'il faut attendre va en profiter
pour vous parler du sponsor de cette
vidéo et vous expliquer pourquoi
j'utilise nord vpn quand je vais à
l'étranger avec hull a vu un j'aimerais
remercier tout particulièrement norvez
pn sponsoriser ce blog j'ai pas si vous
avez déjà vu cette vidéo n'est pas
disponible sur votre territoire ce genre
de truc très frustrant avec un vpn ça
permet de contourner ça d'avoir une épée
française un peu partout dans le monde
avec un abonnement et nous permet
notamment de changer la localisation de
votre ip vpn stamm aussi de protéger vos
données
et si vous vous connectez parfois sur
des connexions internet genre c'est
gratuit vous connecter mais en fait il
ya quelqu'un qui vous pirates et donc
normes et pn ça vous sert pour crypter
votre connexion internet ya forcément
une réduction avec un code promo le code
promo c'est etienne c'est pas vrai c'est
cyprien voilà le lien et la description
vous avez un mois supplémentaire gratuit
et je crois si tu te tires le téléphone
de ma poche
on a beaucoup de passer vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on se rend à la fête de fin de tournage
avec toute l'équipe technique et les
comédiens ils vont découvrir ma nouvelle
coupe de cheveux et bien évidemment
c'est un échec
comme c'est notre dernier soir à tokyo
on va un petit peu profité de la ville
va jouer à mario kart au jeu de tyco
faire quelques petites photos souvenirs
[Musique]
ah ah
on a aussi fait du baseball ça c'est
génial regardez le talent de françois
bon j'ai pas loin de me moquer parce que
moi c'est encore pire et lui il a réussi
à toucher la balle au moins il va même
la touche et une deuxième fois à
regarder non je suis un petit peu
emballé merci d'avoir regardé ce blog au
japon ces dix jours ont été incroyables
pour moi merci norvez pn merci les
éditions kana
le court métrage va sortir très bientôt
j'espère qu'il va vous plaire on a donné
tout notre coeur de d'en rester pas loin
quand il sortira
moi j'ai plein de souvenirs dans la tête
et je vous dis à très vite
[Musique]